[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بعد يوم على
توقيفه بتهام الفساد رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان اودع قيد
الحبس الاحتياطي لمده ثمانيه ايام وفق
محاميه وذلك بعد ان وجهت المحكمه اليه
لائحه اتهامات تتعلق ببيعه هدايا حكوميه
بشكل غير قانوني خلال فتره رئاسته للوزراء
اي من سنه 2018 الى 2022
كما اعتقلت المئات من انصار عمران خان
خلال او لتورطهم في اعمال عنف منها مهاجمه
مباني حكوميه والتسبب باضرار ماديه بمرافق
عامه الحكومه الباكستانيه طلبت من الجيش
التدخل لحظ الامن كما فرضت سلطات حاله
طوارئ في ثلاثه من اقاليم البلاد الاربعه
كما توعد مسؤولون في الحكومه الباكستانيه
القائمين على الهجمات التي وصفوها
بالمنظمه بعدم التسامح وفقا للقانون فيما
دعا حزب عمران خان دعى انصاره الى
الاحتشاد في العاصمه والى اغلاق البلاد
التي يبلغ عدد سكانها 220 مليون نسمه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا الدكتور عبد
الكريم شاه مدير مركز للدراسات السياسيه
اهلا بك من السماوات كذلك صحفي احمد
القريشي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا معك دكتور عبد الكريم دكتور عبد
الكريم في الواقع
عمليه ايقاف عمران خان كانت منتظره
وحضرتكم تعلمون بانه كانت هناك عده دعاوى
قضائيه بحقه للتحقيق معه منذ فتره هو كان
حاضر معنا في لقاء خاص على قناه العربيه
وسالناه في هذا الاطار سالناه ما
الاسباب وراء تعدد الدعاوى القضائيه اكد
بان الهدف سياسي بالاساس ما رايك دكتور
عبد الكريم
هو انصاره فعلا متمسكين بهذا الشيء يقولون
ان
القضايا ضد او ملاحقته هذه كلها قضايا
ملفقه تم فبركتها
وهو فعلا انصاره او شعبيه او شعبيه كبيره
جدا في اوساط الشعب الباكستاني
وجميعهم متفقين على انه اكثر اساسا ما
يتسمون بالنزاهه لان الساسه الذين تعاقبوا
على الحكم فيما مضى جميعهم لوحق دائما
بالفساد وحتى هو شخصيا كان برنامجه
الانتخابي هو
محاسبه الفاسدين
فهؤلاء
بان عمران خان كان اكثر اساس الباكستانيين
النزاهه
هكذا يرى انصاره طبعا هم اغلبيه ساحقه من
الشعب الباكستاني له شعبيه
انا شخصيا ارى ان هذه
الدعاوى طبعا فيه مبالغه كبيره جدا لان
هذه الاراضي اللي اتهموها بانه
استلمها كهديه من شخص يعمل في عقارات وهو
كان متهم
بالرشاي وغسل الاموال ومحكمه في بريطانيا
حكمت
بان لديه اموال مودعه في بنوك بريطانيه
وهي تبعا نتيجه لغسيل الاموال وحتى عمرا
خان في نفس هذا اللقاء الخاص مع العربيه
قال بانه الموضوع تكرر مع سياسيين اخرين
وحتى في دول اخرى كانت هناك عمليات بيع
للهدايا وهذا لا يضطر البعض بحسب تصريحاته
ولكن استاذ احمد ما رايك فيما تفضل به
الدكتور عبد الكريم هو يقول بان هناك
مبالغه في التعامل مع ق ضيه عمران خان
وبان الموضوع كما يراه انصاره السياسي
بالاساس هل هو سياسي او هو ملفات حقيقي
قبل 11 عاما كان عمران خان في زياره لكندا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتم توقيفه
في مطار تورنتو الدولي او مطار انتاريو في
كندا نتيجه مذكره توقيف صادره عن وزاره
العدل الامريكيه والان عندما نتكلم عن
عمران خان في هذا الوقت هناك تحقيق لم يتم
اغلاقه الى الان في اروقه وزاره العدل
الامريكيه يرتبط بممارسات او جمع اموال
داخل امريكا من المواطنين امريكيين
باكستانيين من اصول باكستانيه تم
استخدامها
جمعت هذه الاموال لاعمال خيريه قام قام
بها عمرها الخانه يعني قام بجمع هذه
الاموال لكن تم صرفها في اوجه صرف اخرى
غير معروفه ومشبوهه جزء منها طبعا في
الحمله السياسيه او الحملات السياسيه
العمران الانتخابيه في الانسان لكن اموال
اخرى اختفت فيعني هذا مثال واحد فقط من
امثله كثيره هناك قضايا مهمه السؤال هو
ممكن ان يتم تلفيق في باكستان
الوضع السياسي الباكستاني والسياسه
الباكستانيه معروفه يعني ليست نزيهه ممكن
ان يقوم معارضوه عمران هذا هذه حقيقه ولكن
السؤال هو اذا كان عمران خان نزيها وهو
رجل دوله ورئيس وزراء سابق الا يفترض به
ان يمتثل امام القانون ويثبت نزاهه امام
القضاء ما قام به عمران خان خلال السنه
الماضيه خلال الاثنين شهر اللي فاتوا هو
انه استخدم طريقه تلو الاخرى لعدم
الامتثال امام هيئه مكافحه الفساد والرد
على اسئله المحققين الباكستانيين الذين
لديهم ادله لانه
في كل الاحوال هو بحسب رايها استاذ احمد
عندما سالناه على نفس هذه النقطه هو قال
لانه التحقيق سياخذ وقت وسيضر به وبحزبه
في الانتخابات القادمه واضاف كذلك في نفس
هذه المقابله على قناه العربيه منذ فتره
وجيزه على فكره مش طويله قال بانه
المقصود هو حرماني من الانتخابات من
الانتخابات وليس اعتقالي وليس سجني بمعنى
اذا تركت في هذه الانتخابات سافوز وهم
يعلمون ذلك فيريدون اعتقالي هذا تلخيص
مقاله
اعتقال عمران خان لا يمنع من المشاركه في
الانتخابات
الاعتقال حصل يعني هذه القضيه التي تم
اعتقاله فيها مستمره منذ تقريبا سنه
ويرفض هو المثول امام المحققين بالنهايه
اضطروا المحققين وهيئه مكافحه الفساد ان
ينقل القبض عليه اين في داخل مجمع القضاء
او محكمه العليا الباكستانيه
السؤال هو انه اذا كنت نزيها واذا كنت
سياسيا نزيها عليك الامتثال القانون ودافع
عن نفسك
والشعب يرى
والناخبون يرون وسيرون طبعا اذا ما تم
منعك من المشاركه في الانتخابات لكن
الحقيقه هي ان هذه كلها يعني ذرائع
يستخدمها عمران خان وحسبه
لعدم الامتثال امام المحققين ربما كذلك
السيد احمد لانه لا يثق في القضاء هو كذلك
حدثنا عن هذه النقطه هو قال باني مستهدف
من شخصين من قاضي رفيع وكذلك من احد
المسؤولين في الجيش ولكن دكتور عبد الكريم
ما رايك فيما يتفضل به الاستاذ احمد هل
هناك ازمه ثقه في القضاء ضيفي يقول بطريقه
واضحه وصريحه ان كان عمرا خان نزيه فليقدم
وثائقه ودلائله ويثبت براءته
هو لم ينكر ابدا النسور امام القضاء هذه
القضيه التي تم توقيفه فيها هذه القضيه
استدعيت للمسهول امام المحكمه يوم اجازه
يوم اول مايو يعني قبل عشره ايام من الان
وحتى اليوم عندما
مصر امام المحكمه قال للمحكمه هو لم يكن
يدري انه مطلوب هذه هذا الطلب
للمسؤول امام المحكمه تم
ارساله على عنوان معين عنواني لكن هو لم
يستلمه
فعندما كان مثل امام المحكمه في قضيه اخرى
طبعا بالمناسبه
سجلت ضده اكثر من 140 قضيه من الارهاب الى
اشياء غريبه جدا وفعلا يعني عندما ننظر
الى نوعيه هذه القضايا خلال ثمانيه اشهر
140 قضيه وهو كل من محكمه الى اخرى ولكن
القضيه الاخيره
على اثرها ليست قضيه ارهاب القضيه الاخيره
هي قضيه بيع هدايا تتبع للدوله صحيح وهنا
كذلك هناك سؤال ملفت لماذا ثمانيه ايام
ايقاف كان يمكن ان يكون تحت صراح شرطي
يعني يذهب يتم التحقيق معه ويعود الى
منزله ربما اسالك سيد احمد في هذا الاطار
لماذا ثمانيه ايام مسجون حتى يحقق معه في
ملف فساد له قتل له ارهاب له قضيه كبيره
لا القضيه كبيره القضيه تتعلق
اعراضي عقاريه مهمه جدا
استولى عليها رئيس الوزراء
ويورد فيها ايضا اسم زوجته من تاجر عقارات
كبير وفيها بلايين روبيات يعني قضيه كبيره
هي لكن سؤالك مهم جدا
الاجابه هي بسيطه جدا
باختصار
عمران خل نستخدم كل الذرائع الممكنه
لتفادي المثول امام المحققين
انتهى التوقيت سيد احمد اعذرني على
المقاطعه سنعود لهذا الموضوع بالتاكيد
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا كذلك للضيفه يا دكتور
عبد الكريم اتينا الى نهايه بانوراما لهذا
المساء السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات